live and I'm playing Lila chess
wait no I don't want to play blindfold
No
why am I playing Lila chest blindfolded
change my settings
I forgot I had a student
- hey I was playing blindfold against
uh why is Lila Chesaning
a blindfold no refresh
okay beautiful and I'll play an Enzo
hey hero is back
finally making it to a stream and I'm
finally streaming at at the normal time
normal being almost 11:30 p.m.
let's play a qgd
last time I played Lila chest she was
playing a key for and then some kind of
c3 Sicilian I have not had this opening
yet I'm kind of empted to play c6 here
but then I wouldn't want to go into like
any short Botvinnik - lets just play
Bishop e7
always streamed wins
I'm sorry about the timing
that was not intentional
I'm already happy with this position
because the trade on d5 so early should
usually benefit black I was Bishop f5 p6
and castle
normal
and someone understood my stream title I
have one challenge pending bishop effort
let's start with Caesar
challenge from AJ for15 play you next
I wonder if this person is watching the
stream or just randomly challenged me
sometimes people just around randomly
challenge me on me chess so AJ if you're
in the chat feel free to say hello
zero challenging me to okay it to see
challenges what's happening here h3 is
actually a very typical move in these
positions
Quincy - also typical move preventing
any Bishop f5
attempted to play 96
use of night before
to rely on some intuition here
a three
wila chest showing some fear okay I'm
gonna play Knight c7 idea of 96 the
long-term positional idea for black
let's imagine white just developed
normally III Bishop d3 black wants to
play 96 play this Bishop will move hmm
maybe back to h2
play g6 Knight g7 and Bishop f5
all about trading on flight squared
bishop
ah
Luke G hello I'm in st. Louis I'm at I'm
in a basement a brick thing behind me is
part of a fireplace
I haven't yet tried to use the fireplace
I probably won't I
I've been told not to play with fire I'm
gonna play Knight g7 here
three and night and a challenge for
three minutes okay
I'm gonna accept the AJ challenge first
because he was the first person to
challenge me assuming he's a person play
a five here maybe I should play a six
lowdown the minority attack
Ezard booj thanks for watching the
commentary thank you for the comments
good to see that at least someone is
watching I'm gonna play Bishop at five
positional dreams coming true
idea is if he takes and I take I mean
the bishops are bound to be traded and
my dream is to eventually have this
might come to d6
I can probably pre-move 9f5 and if I get
the Knight to d6 this is what's known as
a Capablanca Knights
and if you've been watching any of the
st. Louis commentary you'll know
hopefully know this idea I'm very fond
of I'm like combining very well with
blacks pawn structure
and also controlling a lot of key
squares in the center or c4 also b5
which in many cases can slow down the
minority attack Oh actually someone
happy here we have a positional game
anything to avoid tactics they rookie
eight we reposition the bishop on g7
did 13 also known as mr. Donuts now I'm
hungry
Brooke a work fa1 when is this move
no idea what the plan is I'm just going
to keep improving
we were just thinking
[Music]
wisely the chesses rating solo
oh this is rapid oh yes that's although
Queen c7 White has no idea what to do so
he's just shuffling around pieces
the problem is that like playing a
computer like this uh probably the
opponent will have a lot more patience
than me and at some point I might I
might go a bit too crazy so I have to
control my eye craziness maybe I'll play
Knight Fe for
for some attack
I'd see five is coming
you
late night c4
I see five is still coming
but the annoying
ah what to do
I'm curious if I play Knight c4
I'd see 5 b6
you
you
you
I'm gonna play a flexible move Queeny
seven
not going to change too much in the
position
they play rook 88 at some point and just
see what white is doing okay now I see
what White's doing going for the very
thematic pawn b5
maybe now it's time to play Knight c4
now I just want to play pawn to e5
myself
now if I move the b-pawn c6 won't be a
weakness because my night is beautifully
placed on c4 a5 so positional
let's play 94
there's actually a game we were
commentating on today between neil
dragon and Robert Haga saurian which
featured this very similar structure
also came from a Queens gambit declined
can i play 92
I hope is that Lila will move back to to
c2 and then I can escape with a draw
that's not going to happen or is it it's
like we need three
I also completely forgot when I take off
to run since it may take F to ever mind
see five okay not going for a petition
well now can i play night take F to be
boolean 24 hello
I take F to King take F to Queen take
III I mean
if I were white I would be scared
if I were like a strong computer I
probably wouldn't be scared
taketake taking f1
ah chess is so complicated
I move the Queen somewhere and the King
runs away
trade nights
that only helps wait
five
looks bad though
okay I'm gonna play I'm just gonna try
and keep it quiet in 86 having another
cup of vodka nights a happy cue bird
just messaged me asking to play well I
have seven pending challenges
uh so let me think
why I wanna advance kingside ponds
I am running low on time though let's
improve the rook intuitive move
won first place at angled splits
tournaments graduations
we
you
but the Queen somewhere more or scary on
h4 not sure what it's doing there
sure what white is doing in this
position like these rooks are ridiculous
it may be trying to invade v6
just gonna play rookie seven
this is exactly the type of game I want
against an engine where there's no
progress to be made on Queen side at
least I don't think there is
but the rook here
my Knights defend each other I mean both
Knights are attacked but I don't think
it's a problem
bathing whether to take on III that's
probably a terrible move
hello two-leaf that a new person might
be a new person
actually don't know what to do here my
pieces are perfect
let's not flag
I'm just going to move back to my Queens
kind of stuck
I have no idea what to do having to play
King eh it's a complete waiting move
you
I'm below a minute so I have to move
quickly I'm hoping that like she just
keeps waiting I'll play King g8 game
time Sahra eh XD is asking how long the
stream is going to be it's gonna be as
long as it takes for me to get sleepy
but we'll see
I'll play at least a few games
I say new person
you think I mean baby I'm not referring
to baby
I guess babies are new people
that makes any sense
Oh what is Leela doing playing like a
human attacking the exchange
or upon
d6 is coming and that actually chopped
Sorek how do I get out of that 48 maybe
the crazy computer move when your stock
fish should play this
we're playing a 5/5 game
play queen g5
I mean I'm up material
and I'm defending everything I think
between d5
I'm just low on time
fifty-five do I take with pawn or rook
probably rook
more trades merrier
five scary
how do i improve my bishop and also how
do I not fug
maybe h5 here
but for some pawn trade
I feel like this is a decently high
quality game do I take and I play King
g8 by King G a truck c4 is just a
ridiculous food I don't know what what
white is doing
I do have to move quickly while I can
just to gain time I don't know what to
do
in a fades hiking route 7
maybe at some point I'll play g5 but the
King on g6 and then go for f5
not thrilled about my deep on being
fixed on a dark square but
you late
g6
I just want to play our five
does the problem about this position
there's no open files which means my
rooks can't have too much fun if I would
be a blunder probably let's bring the
rook back
and then very soon I'll go for f5
yeah I don't think Lila chesses at stock
fishes level yaks but who knows Ange
you
problem is White has more center pawns
if I push the pawn I'm gonna be patients
this is kind of stressful
time no clear plan from this position
a king each one makes me happy because
white clearly doesn't have a plan either
but maybe at some point will repeats
probably okay with a draw given that
I don't see a light I don't see a
breakthrough I mean I could go for a g4
but that might be overextending
see there's messages in the chat it's
hard to keep up I'm just gonna keep
moving around
I wonder if Lila chest has been
programmed not to take repetition when
it's not necessary
because that's it seems to be that's
what it's doing let's put the work back
on d5
I'm okay repeating I'm
to offer a draw
Richenda says it is programmed to do
that interesting
let's put the bishop back on at 6:00
see I can flag it or flag her
hey I drew Lela chess this is my second
draw ever I finally have 1.2 14 points
I'm so happy right now and that was a
decent game that was not just like an
opening draw like the first time I drew
Lela chess was some like repetition out
of the opening but I thought this game
it was I mean it was an interesting
positional battle I used some typical
ideas and these things gambit declined
positions mainly this this whole night
maneuver
which looks strange but
a relatively typical you didn't say GG
how rude I didn't see I didn't say gg
either I guess I can say GG still
I'll played I guess I sit for the buns
well
I still have yet to beat VHS maybe that
was there is some chance there let's go
to the houses forward I'll accept
challenges very soon
I see stockfish is already running on
this game I didn't prompt it to run
maybe someone else prompted it I see
there's a cater room
uh we I turn off computer analysis
just going to admire
my moves
everything was pretty natural
but like I had a decent grip on the
position 92 is fancy and really do
anything
okay there were some moves in the scheme
from whites which kind of showed the
weakness of the computer like doubling
up the rooks accomplished nothing and
then later this rook c4 move really
wasn't about necessary but rook takes c4
here was somewhat surprising I wanted to
compare rockfish and see if sac fish
would actually say yes
remove on
oh I love suckers loves white in this
position rockfish is finding tactics
might take b7 what
or take
Oh
I mean this is a very forcing line which
you would expect a computer to find sock
fish giving nice
damage to whites maybe this isn't
entirely clear though
I could envision Lila justice maybe
reaching this position even after it
takes you six seeing that black has
extra piece and maybe some attacking
potential on the Kings side
interesting line
yeah that's one thing I would never even
consider if I didn't sock fish let's
just see what happened I'm just curious
how stock fish would evaluate the final
position I think it was relatively equal
B mmm slightly better for Black Knight
take a six are you serious
in sauk fish will give some evaluation
like better for black but I don't think
there's a clear way of making progress
so let's move on I know there's people
watching and you want to play me and I
just want to have my windows configured
in a decent manner include some tabs
seven pending challenges
the stream looks to be okay
well let's accept Oh AJ is not
challenging me the first challenger has
disappeared let's accept hero
and hello strict East's
good to see a new name here
playing hero let's play g3 100% sure I
have not played g3 against him yet
Bishop g2 on Stubblefield hello
I've been watching so much just lately
and not playing that much chess I feel
like getting some something fresh
you're taking suggestions learn how to
play plaque in the opening alright you
want to suggest a black opening or you
just want me to play something that I
would recommend
I can I can do either
f4 was probably not called for but it
makes the position interesting
resembles some sort of Dutch with this
fianchetto maybe I'll go for c4
lots of challenges
I will take opening recommendations guys
want to see an opening let me know say
it in the chat ok the square is weak
also this bishops undefended I have to
take like Queen Queen c1
wait a minute Queen b6 check i've tea
for at the very worst
and go gambit for black
at some point with point a as a proper
noun
um yeah I could uh I mean I don't know
too much about the bank oh I just know
that Deus you sack up on for positional
compensation
so if I have any black games and I run
into beef or I can try and play it
billion with 2e6 that's what I normally
play
I've
feeling this should not work
be wrong
I take you 595 rook tikki five when I
for got five
interesting
you
i takee 5.85 it's just III Brooke will
move
let's do that
you
so III box Queen
you
and Confused a weird position
[Music]
three removes 92
at least it's solid
I can't play 92 because III hang
I'll save Knight c-4 in that position
fouled as Julio Francisca
I'm not a green fella player I mean I
could try playing it it's a very trendy
opening these days while the top teams
are playing it but it never really
inspired me
too much by Queens 84 as possible all
Queens 84 is a move I would have been
crushing haha
um
that were the firts
Klee I'm alive
down upon
what happens in blitzen's simple tactics
go unnoticed
you
the one thing I like about this position
is uh
box queenside development is a bit slow
can actually applies equally three night
u2's week
just going to place III
now this night can only really move to
c7
I'm from the c7 it can really move to e6
or kind of interfere with the bishop so
it's a bit awkward for black
and in the meantime I'm an employee of
the strategy that I usually employ
against here oh it's just a matter of
playing quickly and going for the flag
also going for maybe some attack 27
potential
maybe at some point g4
27 and g4 could be strong
I don't think I care about this pawn I
guess now it's too late
Queen c7
running a queen trade
you
you
on the Queen trade but yes I have to
trade
I'll play a for the Knights
working for
you
this is a type of position I want a capo
Blanca nights
let's start with this
you
now this is three plus two so
Flagg unless he I see flags
like half of Locker nights
you have to is coming
[Music]
I wants to come here
do I do
I put the night here
interesting
you
this is a fight
night versus bishop
sometimes bishops are inherently better
in these types of positions but nights
are trickier and the time scramble
and King here in the night here
on there
I
you
things are heating up when I get my
night to c5
fact the positions kind of closing down
so my night should just be extra
favorable against the bishop
this is pretty funny situation uh but
now I'm winning upon
about to flag to
this flag
hey I won
um yeah that wasn't the best positional
play especially this move f5 completely
unnecessary maybe the idea is to play H
for it but this bishop has to be nice to
your pieces
there would be some chances like bishop
fi put the bishop on e4 and then playoff
five
because black house it is two-on-one
majority maybe there's something to play
for a good game though miss ting weird
opening
or how bad would Queens 84 be for me
because it pretty much wins a rook
I would have seven
you
so I guess black can just take on e5
just so much better
sad why you should never trust your
opponents especially if it's me okay
we're gonna move on let's play another
person
for Siri
the number between one and nine
okay mr. donuts challenged me a long
time ago
we're playing bullets as well game
okay good luck
four zero with the 101 bits Thank You
Hiro
always a pleasure to eat you and then
receive bits
I like my position already London
opening I've asked for much more than
this
Bishop her pawn and stay with pawn
always easier to attack on the kingside
when your why than you have upon on e5
the Queen one h6 Bray Heather with a 102
bits for passing hero
I'm an hero at the tube it's okay well
I'm getting distracted
I wonder if these people throwing bits
are just
mr. Donuts entourage attempting to
distract me
I'm also losing this pawn and I'm yeah
I'm just down upon this is a terrible
position what happened to my amazing
London position I'm down on time by like
20 seconds
but I'll come back maybe
I have up on storm
I just want to open some file on the on
this part of the board
oh no my queen
oh this is so bad
I'm sorry mr. Donuts give you a terrible
game I'm in a rematch I need revenge I
was getting distracted I resign
rematch oh my gosh okay we have to put
mr. Donuts in his place let's play the
Fabiano variation
except not really
what does this roof care to move back
well this is boring
on how the petrov ants posed into some
exchange French we're actually pre move
we need to like Olive would have been
risky
I try and grind this down
keep up with the bits this is too
difficult very Hatter currently leading
though under 25
okay he's thinking
well now I'm up 20 seconds nice
now max
I don't know what's going on mr. Joe
that's probably had like um some sort of
health issue
after eating too many donuts
you
yeah I guess he
you just left the game I'm sorry mr.
Donuts
uh we're gonna move on and play someone
else give me a random number between one
and seven Thanks
okay Theatre of crazy
wrong player too 23:05 good luck
I'm still taking opening prep or opening
recommendations if anyone wants to
adjust a black opening against efore
either 50 bits back-to-back what's going
on
I'm not seeing any opening
recommendations I'm just gonna play well
I'm gonna play the dragon was messy
Marvin just in time let's play the
normal dragon
dragon is risky to go into and someone
who be well prepared
uh hopefully
my preparation can hold up the only
thing I know about this position is to
take and play Bishop e6 his White has
not put the bishop on c4 and then I
think Queen a 5
is a move
like rook fc8 our position may be easier
to play in in blitz from the black side
this is okay
mimes when white plays king b1 the
thread is 95 but tactics
you
well I do appreciate the bits everyone
by everyone I mean hero and gray Hatter
you guys are so generous I'd take on e3
and then take on a two
we take C 3 we take it to being a one
rook c8
probably losing material
by b5 on maybe five
Thank You messy Marvin for a good
opening recommendation also to leaf for
the same opening recommendation
and cruel guy with
with Sicilian but spelled Silla silicium
hopefully I fulfilled all of those
recommendations with this game before is
a move I want to play problem is 95 can
happen
maybe I play rugby
they were okay bas
sixty two bits ray Hatter
okay
well now my queen is hanging
lightly unpleasant I guess I have to
take
can I take on d5
trade off everything
calculating
this is three plus two
take on D
for
then he gets a choice which to capture
actually Bishop 285 is interesting
bishops 85 Bishop g7 bishop take out
three wreckage three Bishop to g4 XG 3
you
I don't know
this is complicated
Bishop d7 I don't really want to play
but
I mean if the dark sweat bishops get
true oh I'm just losing a pawn in 87 I
completely forgot about but he doesn't
take it he plays a completely random
move before which makes me really happy
because I can take and play rook c3 and
maybe not be worse his rook d3
[Music]
okay I'll still go for it because then
rook t3 rook c4
hard to keep up with the bit war I see
gray Hatter leading with 301 bits I can
math pretty fast
open files
okay I'm gonna just stick the rook
enough for
probably take with this pawn
I just can't let him like double up on
the H file which means he might play
rook T to work H - that's kind of hard
to stop
or maybe I'll run with the king
at least improve the king
by a six because why not
apologize for auto mod
that was weird
uh let's play I'm the line time
okay I'll trade rooks
I don't know like who actively better
here because my queenside oh my gosh my
Queen side pawns are fixed on light
squares
but it's c5 pawn and f3 pawn or
potentially weak
you
but I usually like these positions it's
usually clear what the plan is I mean I
just want to play Bishop b7 wants to
play c4
okay well let's take and then Bishop e7
and actually my King has a very clear
path to e5 and d5 is going to fall
probably at some point
I'm sorry that that probably made a
really loud sound cuz Mike just like
crashed on itself uh the problem with
the mic is it's on a tripod and the who
okay let's not flag uh let's take the
pawn 85c force coming
I can't stop that
I am
you
let's see for roti for a tick tick tick
five
kind of complicated
eleven seconds left so every move I have
I play has to be instinct
don't really want to play e6 I'm gonna
go for this in game
it's risky though
because both our Kings are getting very
active
come in to attack my bishop my king can
come in to attack his bishop
everything's weak play Bishop see
I Bishop getting trapped
you
my bishop might actually be getting
trapped
okay I almost flagged there that was
close
not sure what's going on
you
you
on
this might just end in a draw
you
yeah this is ending in the draw I think
a four
elzar really weird finale
I'm not accepting a drug because if he
plays for a win he could lose maybe
also you should never accept a draw when
your point offers it on the remove
um but now I still not flag
okay good game I'm sure someone is
something there
I was actually a really interesting
endgame
probably should've lawsuits
infinite flash as specialty five white
missile win
a ship t5 here looks pretty winning
looks very winning
yeah that's that's an easy puzzle I can
show some students I should have taken
probably with my bishop
um
I do want to actually look at the
opening because earlier
I really wanted to play Brooke take c3
also curious when we point out of theory
before I can be one or gassy eight
all theory until each for third most
popular move
Brooke takes c3 scores well for black
dragan idea I just didn't see what to do
after King Siwon
take G for once
we need one Wow me tactics
Bishop to g4 it's brilliance
gives us pawn and defended
I'm like again
the Queen a one
in d2
Mozza games played from here let me see
if this has happened in a masters games
handful
and yeah Black has queen d1 and then
I'll be good position
well useful line to know I don't play
the dragon in the Civil I'm not fully
acclimated to these lines anyway let's
move on
infinite flashed chefs being very
impressed
you
let's add some
okay
well some people have worked yeah let's
accept another challenge a que knife a
name scares me
okay I'll just pick another random
number actually all that Siri pick
another random number give me a random
number between 1 and 10
are you serious
random number between one and ten
all I wanted one two three four
cool guy hey talking with coolguy
earlier shout out to cool guy 2189 rated
1433 uh no I'm not playing Chicago open
but I will maybe be it Chicago open not
sure yet
but we'll see
g5 from passkey
Kanan
what is this opening let's play see five
big things interesting
we
okay I'm gonna play a purely hope chess
move hoping that white blenders will see
if you see
Hey
I hooks came true
five check when the night
ceefor was just a bad positional nervous
white doesn't lose a piece
but okay now I'm happy
ah milf ab6
for the fiend cutter
and then maybe the sneaky tech mates
whoa I just blundered like big-time
Queen Esther he's a brilliant move
threatening to different things that's
not what I wanted but I think I'll live
with it
you can take on f7 I'll run with my king
but things are getting interesting
at least I'm alive
kind of a six-pack on
[Music]
many challenges
chess is difficult
in the stream and all I see is Queen I
three it's not the end of the world like
objectively okay White has compensation
but just lost a bishop I'll give you a
take back because I'm a nice person
should be four
to be forced to better move
the nation chess good to see you
I want to do here
it's hard for a black to develop and not
like make concessions
maybe the plan is just to trade Queens
you
this kind of late after midnight for the
unbelievable
maybe it's time for chocolate
night snack I don't know
want to play you can play well play the
next scene okay after this game we're
gonna have a special guest completely
take over the stream I can take a break
hopefully
I have to finish this game first
in age
well a very annoying position
it's five
going for the app on storm
unchallenging yeah anyone can challenge
me if you don't know how to challenge me
on me Ches and probably figure it out
after go now
okay by strict peace thanks for watching
thank you vibe of 47 for the follow
I completely forgot that people might be
following and I haven't been chatting
them out me maybe rearrange things a
little bit so now if anyone follows I
can out us
I'm the pawns form
ah let me open stream labs
and see anyone else to think
yeah thank you thank you to the new
followers
sure
of 47 leapin yetis
a jinx
11:02 thank you everyone
to see some new faces
b5 is a very strong move actually
aren't so argot many different things in
the position
Oh do I do
play this
you
scary though
you
three
you
vibe of 47 watches English chess club
love them all
thanks for the comments that's my see
here
is vibe aha
Bojan probably not maybe
I know wondering
a lot of that
well this is what I was hoping for
because now my Queen and Bishop doing
some significant damage
you
actually don't know what's going on here
this is actually really complex I could
still up up up material
things a bit shaky
I only grew up take v7 was best I think
he they Eve
it's still interesting
Evans coming
you
Rock still has to be careful maybe Rick
see
let's see
you
oh here here here here
okay my queen actually defends any
potential tuck any potential checks
along the diagonal
and the more pieces that get traded the
happy right
I t5
Gary move but
probably a plunder
you
interesting game though
Oh
technique
you
any can pre moving
you
ah yeah interesting fights
we both fell for each other's traps and
see for such a funny move
serious what's the best response for
whites maybe it's not a terrible move
for black white probably has to move the
bishop back
I can play d5
then later like white could play b3 and
just happy
okay I still have eight pending
challenges
you wanna play game a guest is going to
take over the stream but you can
completely take over a few
I could just
okay I don't know or or we could do like
blindfold
okay just play normal chess uh welcome
to the stream heatheravan i'm sylva
woman grandmaster you can choose like a
game
and then just play anyone
okay hello everyone
I'm first time here so please don't
judge too harshly
all right click on okay I'm playing here
I'm by the tactics I hope that's not
but it's
okay huh I hope I'm not
I'd
I too much
and I was premiering to take
you
yeah this
enter
s-final
he gives me selecting me with a dog
walking in a park
welcome strange person who are you my
name is Katerina Nemcova
I am I'm originally from Czech Republic
but now I live in u.s. past six
I was with Aragon the Webster team
other questions absolutely I will take
over my University scheduler I'm taking
over a stream I think I should learn
more often
yeah I have to do workshop every day two
hours so you can just go and see
Irina she's to play in the women's Chess
Championship yes
actually I played the past three I think
women's championships I just didn't play
this year I had to decline the
invitation because of my school I'm
currently studying PhD in Arizona and it
was just impossible managed one and
what are you idiot I am I think my
reading is now dropped so it's something
like 2310 yes
what are you studying in communication
pH in communication I think this Bishop
is gonna be lost
bouncing
PhD yeah it's our I'm struggling
opening
going for a check might like to attack
you
you
especially if you are by the tactics I
think I want to offer tactics oh and I
see a very nice trick oh you saw it I
want to take on H 339 f3 good job that
bad
you
you
Oh Rocio
you
I feel my parts are looking
you
oh wow 9 H 1 sir
beautiful and we should be one anyway
now you have all the all the pieces of
master rank I really used to play that
game now get all the pieces thank you
no I hear Bishop on D - only - and he
could have been wish everyone
oh good again
okay can I play blindfolded
thank you yes
well then I'll do Ike
or you could reference
that might be
you
it might be difficult
so these don't see anything that's a
casual okay
no not one not one minute that's crazy
three or five anything I'm Kareem Kareem
is a nice name let's you're playing in
1100 every way
is really blindfolded I don't see
anything press older time
you
this is so weird
and is equaling ban by folded as well
you
this is very hard I'm not joking
you
I am scared
let's go
you
it is super hard
it is so hard
you
you
I don't think I'm gonna win this any
you
I'm saying
[Laughter]
something is there what's your time
huh
you
no this is not impressive art
I'm not I'm Cosmo oh he tubes okay okay
I was citizen oh I didn't see the move
okay now I get it
that's why I didn't understand okay all
right I don't have my time so awesome
I just when a queen or is there
something else I have no idea I thought
it's a queen no then it's
can somebody tell me in the chat if it
was a queen or not
nobody can help me
your opponent 700
I don't like if there's not a queen then
you
was a pawn seriously
Oh
there's no clicking
Oh
I
it is a one
something is happening there let's go
early
I'll turn back on the bridge I have
known
oh we got mated what just happened
what happened how come I thought he
played queen bee cream and I had Rokon
be oh he didn't play Queen b3 he played
b3 okay but that was tricky because b3
doesn't make sense and I thought yeah
when they make a move you have to see
yeah I kind of assumed he blundered
and then I was like I blunders a road
did you
do you like this fun okay
you
okay Oh tell her this was I thought he
played Queen b3 and I played c5 and I
was like because the Pawnee Sun hanging
and I was like oh I dropped a rook on PA
and then I thought oh he forgot about it
okay this is really hard I see no pieces
at all on the board okay so let's let's
fix it in play normal and Eric will take
back over
also thanks Braden uh breathing her host
honey for viewer
[Music]
I'm sure
Oh perfect thank you this is so much fun
so k1 has games one another Bible no no
Brian but it's impossible I can do too
tired too slow how magnets
too weak too slow
you get like peace orders
okay so that's my face
you
Wow only 400 okay
that is what is in casual
the factory
oh I kind of messed up your writing
right
because other game
I studied this variation heydon't World
Championship I'm not sure that's really
the line but
I wanted to pay for black and black is
equalizing here actually
without much travellers burn
that's funny I'm crying too I'm going
according to my
you
I'll bring Erick back don't worry some
Eric music please fill us something
oh that's
I like extra pee
let's see how long an hole
and it was very short of holding
you
you
he doesn't
how long have have you an Eric been
together we've been its Webster teammate
since 2000 when did you join
thousand 15 we met Eric us championship
this is so much fun
oh listen
a worse thing in life
on a super rocky Aidan
it hurts
I'm
you
reflect everything on a first rank as
long as I don't lose it long as I don't
have the pieces
you
you don't know your Theor in this line
you're gonna get smashed
hope that's not
actually I think it is I used to just
practice on the test but I'm gonna
create an account and start playing
there seems to be a lot of fun
Eric maybe your Bishop one is gonna
happen
you
your name is Katerina yes correct
I I that that's the one who won with me
in the blind thing
then that's true
and my position here is pretty horrible
um
for this
you
yes
you
Arum you just beat master that's true
you
you
will you play me well Eric is gonna take
over soon but maybe he will play you
oh I lost upon what happened who did
that to me
you
there's no increment all right sir one
second
oh why did I go there okay this is a
horrible idea let's move around
Oh No
no second I want to first
no before the blood
good job all right guys have fun with
Eric I have to do some school work so
much fun maybe I will join you next time
bye
okay that was refreshing
thanks breathe in for good person hahaha
okay let's we only have five having
challenges I'm gonna play
bringing knife or Apollo pots actually
want to try blindfold
don't do it
this machine blips
moving the pieces
you
I've done it before but like three
three-minute could be difficult
uh I'm in the try it is Korean knife at
Korean knife is casual great
preferences
now let's accept Korean nice
drag thanks for following
okay Korean ice letting you blindfold
let me focus okay
we'll play some opening
plenums oh why not
the chef gee I've never goes
and I see sir
I see six is always a hmm a weird
sideline that is playable at least and
makes white think
I had this internment game like I just
didn't know theory after Bishop g5 so I
decided why not Knight knight c6 Gray
had her with the bits thank you
um this is not yet our IP because I have
blindfolded
if you do want to follow the game and
see where the pieces are you can type in
the command Italy chess and you should
be able to acknowledge things
I don't mind the position seems okay
nine up to three
lady six
you
I'm up a pond right I haven't lost upon
yet
I'll play e5 next
- which is very important
open G file maybe for the rook
stuff is happening
[Music]
to you
you
d5 I can't move the night because
cleaning for a check so I guess I have
to take
and play this
I used to struggle with mindful but
recently I've been getting better
it just takes a lot more focus
ID for that's a move
I'm not mistaken
[Music]
can i play rook to you Oh safe and make
the move
I'm not mistaken we both have just one
minor piece
bishop on c 94
on structures a bit weird I'm attacking
the g2 pawn
[Music]
um wait no I have a knight on e5 am I
talking about
you play queen h5 so where's this other
minor piece
Valon I see okay
okay going at your five try to keep
track of things
play Bishop e7 No
do
plate rook g7 defend the pawn
okay so the bishops on f1 94
you
you
bhishma hop on f1 is stuck is my ruckus
pressuring the pond so he plays f3 let's
play Bishop d7
castles queenside
Castle queenside hence position Bishop
e2 can I take on
let's take the pawn
Brooke HR fine
move back and defend
you
for my Nikon stuck
so I have to plain a g6
you
that's really annoying let's take
you
move the night back
you
you
it's attacking my queen blue Queenie
southern
Keating's defended
Queen take h6 was on each six
oh the pond okay let's play this defend
the rook
yeah
sorry
timeout sure Queen d2 let's Viking
buttes
this is where it gets tricky
there's not too much time to think
where's my pieces
episode 97
you
you
I just got maded wait what
oh I was moving my King around and he
made it me
[Music]
what is going on
you
there's a twitch staff person what is
this this is really weird
challenged me to a game
um
oh I see interesting
twitch staff person
ah
awkward how do i okay shout out to Manas
Paul he 1 to 12
I thought it was a
I'm used to like
add very self advertisers joining but
interesting uh what's your leach SEO
keep their this okay let's play at which
staff person this is interesting I want
to know I want to turn
it is maybe slightly suicide let me turn
back on blindfold off blindfold
okay there you go
hey I can see pieces
twitch staff don't know what that means
but
I guess you're slightly a god to me in
some ways I'm gonna play a London
because that's all I know how to play
on III 9 on c6 not the most radical move
this is playable though
the pollen c3
chiffon g3 gray Hatter with 20 more bits
it means you lose if you want to keep
not even mean
okay he really wants to play e5 so I'm
gonna play 95
blind wrist find game yes I'm interested
Belen probably just done with blindfold
for the Knights
um
interesting position
Bishop's but slightly weak pawn on e5
I'd like to play f4 maybe queen h5 let's
start with that for
don't feel you need to play a Paulo box
trying to make humans happy I I do see
the the challenge from the bots but it's
a bot and it doesn't have feelings and I
feel like humans are happier when they
get the chance to play me but
I'll have to try and play a Paulo bot at
some point
you
I don't know if I met her here this is
uh
but we're position
Black has developed where the
set up as weird
me I should still go fairy Sun kingside
play
like Queen h5 I'm gonna start with queen
h5
and try and bring this Knight to g5
for him
if you beat the person in charge of
twitch might find it hard to keep me
yeah please don't ban me from twitch if
I beat you
but the person in charge of twitch is
like Jeff Jeff Bezos writes his Amazon
Owens twitch and he's a CEO of Amazon
now how it works not sure
I just want to play Knight g5
my g5 is an interesting line ig5 bishop
Dixie to Queen degage 7 king of AIDS
there might not be a follow-up
you
I didn't really want to trade these
bishops but I guess I have to
rookie to
move play rook d1 he'll play c4 l plane
out of five
Queen f8
someday I might want to play f5
with Bishop Iman
he's playing quickly
also playing quickly
I like this pawn storm f5 is coming
Russian robot of twitch streaming
okay
this is kind of scary
this is 3/2 so I do have time to think
ponder my moves this f6 square is going
to be very nice for a bishop it's just a
question how to execute
take-take-take
you
hmm
you
probably should not be taking too much
time here
this position just
you
I really don't want to close it up okay
I'm gonna play this
he's going to take plane at five we'll
trade I'll get my bishop to f6
but I'll be slightly worse
win first that later good advice
you
serious to watch the stream I'm going to
open it in a new tab
is it wrong to watch the stream probably
because this is a rated game
close it for now
oh this is a rated game
reading is on the line
they move
very strong
I guess I have to play g5 so sad
I might sack someday I'm d3
like right now because the night was so
annoying
the issue is I can't allow open files to
be created but this is annoying
this is really bad
for this
I could lose this game
I'm going to fight though out in seconds
left
maybe three
you
go for this move
each five why not
you
not a good position means
traded uh bring the King to f2 and try
and cocoon
this is really really really bad
this is really bad
Oh
No
Oh
there's it before is a good try
but there's going to be a meeting that
somewhere
maybe
maybe not
you
I'm trying my best
I'm kind of failing but okay ricocheted
is coming my only hope
you
I do have
there
no my rook I forgot about rock I had to
play rotate shades
well I'm now I'm losing a good game
ya know he played a good game why did I
lose a rook like that
this is just a losing position now
I play this
then you would play this
I'm confused okay one more game time to
get revenge gg
obviously we're not cheating
someone wanted me to play a Banco gambit
earlier it's time to play a Banco
gambits
hey gray had her giving 20 bits for not
flagging I should knock flag more often
no a five take back okay I didn't that
mean to play a five it's so sad oh he
gave me a take back that's so nice
well I played g6 thinking he wasn't
gonna give me a take back now okay we're
transposing into some Banco gambit line
now I'll play Bishop g7
who wanted me to play banco gambit
earlier if you're still in the chat let
me know or if you if you play banco
gambit yourself let me know i'm curious
how many of you people actually exists
uh do I take the pawn lady six
little Plotkin are you playing Chicago
open through 64 is also playing Chicago
open we should have a twitch Meetup
we should do like a massive dream
if Christians playing probably not
you
I mean I actually playing Chicago open
but I'll be there at some points
not sure when but
I'll definitely be stopping by maggiore
good
I actually saw a crew 64 in person just
a few days ago in Nashville we were both
like at the same hotel for the same
weekend for like three days in a row and
we didn't realize it until the very last
day
okay this game I feel a little bit
better about myself at the time
advantage have some pressure just have
to keep up the speed
i p5 coming
every day
I might go everyday I don't know
like I I have somewhat of a life outside
of going to Chicago open every day I t4
happens
you
I want to play Queen b3 index
so I'm hoping you please
bad move
let's play Queen b3
I'm Benko gambits a great opening
against people who don't know how to
play against bingo gambit
life is so happy for black
leave this move
it doesn't do anything
ooh I see tactics but they don't work or
do they work okay [ __ ]
ninety-two
by night see too
wait a minute that was a terrible move
please don't punish me
to punish me
this is bad
oh he doesn't punish me I thought 92 is
swimming there
well going to the slime
okay for
are you playing in spank oh the way you
play against panko is 12a for
um there's
that became popular like several years
ago and once it became popular from the
white side black stops playing the Banco
I kind of want to sack the exchange in
this position it's completely uncalled
for
Brook take a three take take
yeah it's actually just uncalled for
I'll take on see-through
you
you
oh no I am not married
no rings right
actually sometimes wait let me magic
trick I think I can do this on screen I
have you see this I have I'm spreading
my fingers
I only have four fingers okay
can I take on let's take the Queen and
positionally
I should do more magic on stream
I forgot that I can do magic
I don't even have a coin
do everything with credit cards these
days
you
I win this game I'll I'll finish off the
stream with a magic trick
maybe the magic trick will be winning
this game as it's not easy
I love this this positional play like
look at these beat pawns
it's just bread and butter on the play
reggae forums when upon
nice he's going for active play but now
the plan is to do this in this
magical
you
you
you
I've comes and the spine can't be
defended
can be but then he loses this
or good good try
bigots
you
I'm going to open his stream in the new
tab
take more pawns
him don't take more pawns
how does he feel right now
Iman when I hear him cry
you
oh he's actually defending here
that's all I wanted to hear
uh let's go back and finish this game
off I have five pawns
can we trade off all the rooks
can play rook h8 so annoying please play
rook eh eh oh this is so annoying
[Music]
and so annoyed right now play f4
you
now I can do this
and this
now on a sac upon but I'll sack upon
you
because I wanted to do this oh he took
upon and he's defending against mates
but I still have three pawns
good enough to him
you
he is a fighter
you
okay um play one more game I'm so tired
want to play him
I'll play one more game easy
on more I need revenge I need to beat
him two out of three
final game bubbly for this game
I was lost
I play my favorite opening
uh II 6 like this week
oh geez
I'll trick him I'm gonna place some kind
of
[Music]
hopefully he's confused oh very confused
following Sandra Nonie
three prophylaxis
and complain with opening a Forza move
here
at four looks nice
I'll probably end up playing a for
restrict d5 advance
you
I'm sorry to the people who are still
challenging me maybe I'll have to play a
Paulo bot some points in the future
I'm really tired I want to do right
you
I'm gonna be right back I'm gonna find
something magic with
you
you
oh okay
did not mean to kick the table like that
I want my night to go deceiver
I have to
patience
you
okay do you see that the cracker
you
you
it's gone
you
but actually okay here's a magic trick
while the camera will pick this up
you
I should actually focus in this position
thank you for the one bit for the worst
trick ever
now this position is actually getting
really
I want to play Queen eh five packs and
pawns
what pieces on the kingside
Baku's in the chat good to see you
I'm gonna do this move
I have a good feeling about this he has
to take I take back up to his hips his
Knights kind of loose queen a3 back in
some positions
95 is impossible can take work off
eights impossible and Ricky 7 is
impossible because I can take the g6
when we move we're in f3 Knight a5 g4
Oh then here's 95 so Queen a three-night
of 5g 495 queen up for
Oh looks good
you
sometimes I'll check like all my
calculations but here I'm just I don't
feel like double-checking looks good I'm
gonna go for it
this is my is Oh his knight on e5
defends of pawn and half seven I forgot
about that
so this Knight can safely move away and
he's okay but f6 is weeks 194 is coming
and the knight f6 will come I'm bad at
drawing arrows
especially when it's late
okay you see the cracker
wait one sec one sec
you
you
you see the cracker I take the cracker
it's too difficult on the small camera
I would need a bigger camera I think I
have a thumb trick
you
no doesn't work also Knight f6 works
turn Elizabeth hello nirvana Raymond
just in time for some really bad magic
tricks
my night is more valuable than this rook
I'm going to do
I had to try euros but a clean edge for
him and try and made him somehow
also he's about to flag
this one makes me so happy
you impressed
on facades always emphasized
also take care of it then rugged shape
I
I love cheese
Arata I'm gonna take and then try and
get the Queen to g7 somehow oh this is
just massive destruction
okay that was really fun
okay
one again
hooha you wanna play about
play a bot or you can play
okay you're going to play a 22
okay welcome back Katarina nem Silva Oh
everyone
let's see what's happen
yeah and thank you I don't know how to
say thank you for the game
I think you heard me very
as so
thank you for working with time
all right some interviews I mean just
starting on
ever
whoa five years
it makes sense Kings gambit enough
mic is nothing out who's your mine are
your stars oh okay I got scared I lost
to be sure but I think it's happening
I'm good
who is that Catarina that's me
Oh a regular in trouble somebody told
you not to beat the TWiT staffer
we crush somebody's carrier I won't
carry
Oh
watching
you
okay
[Music]
oh that's good but Oh
um shoes understand I have some issues
audio is coming out because I'm not
actually one of them oh yeah oh oh hello
your call 1 7 how Eric would say it or
how 117 how normal person would pay it
I still think I have some compensation
for a piece rising 'we are like not
developed at all okay now they are
why go after the rook
awesome
Wow I'll see I see so many tactics
please bring back DTV who's that
I have no idea
yeah whatever
and now I think you will be
why not community 5 I do want to play
queen h5 but I couldn't before because
there was Queen on before and now I feel
like it's still not a checkmate so I
will wait with that
but it's a very good idea I plant
if I can play it right
okay looks fun but I can't play it
this Ike and it looks pretty cool
how much higher rated are you doing Eric
jerk-off I think I have to disappoint
you I think I have like couple less pop
oh wait what's happening here sorry I
have less points than Eric I don't know
what is our writing difference
again I think I can check me today and I
cannot smell the cream
no I couldn't because there's always
Queen d7 give me 7
you
you
you
I didn't lose that night right
your phone is vibrating and it's just
you don't em Eric
you
I'm two pieces for rock which is not bad
why are changing good bishops with
bedrock well I was I thought I was going
to win a piece I was why I wasn't but I
still have some tricks there
I was the owner hi Steven
let's see what do you want to go
I can think back
three is fine we know III
you know hello hello jury array
okay I think this is simply bad
you
here
ya know I take something
maybe it worked but this is a Caesar
sometimes I don't play for
wrote x fi di maybe it worked but you
know why I'm just going here and I will
just take Reba shop I don't get this oh
oh why don't you get these guys I'm over
for this guy
Oh what's happening Oh bless you
I meant it they are going to do
good game AGV Praveen Sahara
I don't think I think it's too late guys
it's 1:26 here in st. Louis we are going
to do broadcasting I am it was fun I
enjoyed it
maybe I'll be back bye guys
yeah we running the stream
but
while gray Hatter with a non stop this
before we end
one last magic actually I just wanted to
see if anyone else is dreaming
andressa screaming this is perfect so we
are going to raid a dress
right now
nine viewers
Oh not too many people are watching
right now but let me type in the command
raid I am underscore undress
yeah thanks messy Marvin for watching
I'll be back in the future there we go
goodbye and good nights off